the whole reason that my whole life I've
wanted to get into radio is because if
you have a radio channel or radio show
you get a jingle I signed up with Sirius
we have a brand new channel series
Channel 106 Team Coco radio and sure
enough they have in-house these
professional singers who do Jingles for
the channel I was in television for
almost 30 years I never got a goddamn
jingle this is the grand unveiling of
the Team Coco radio jingle let's do it
two two go Team Coco radio
[Music]
that's fantastic thank you very much
thank you and I love that part at the
end can I hear that again just the last
part
perfect that's the sound I make after
I've eaten an entire ham by myself I
love it but I think we can do more Team
Coco radio at the bottom of the show is
totem pole
[Music]
thank you
the [ __ ] was that
bottom of the Showbiz totem pole did one
of my writers come up with that yeah oh
and that's a fun joke for you bottom of
the show is totem pole we weren't sure
we were really allowed to sing totem
pole what they're inherently
non-hierarchical
it's just some PC thing where you can't
mention a totem pole yeah as a matter of
fact oh you don't think SiriusXM is
hierarchical when I go to see the CEO I
go up to 75 flights of stairs past a lot
of people who have no say in what
happens around here
he's actually a molecular biologist is
that true yes it is why are you here
that's how I support my singing career
wait a minute you're a molecular
biologist I absolutely am do you realize
there's been a pandemic and you're here
singing goddamn Jingles have you done
anything to help with the covid crisis
tried to find Inhibitors of the viral
protease during the early part of the
pandemic
laughs
did you ever start to like move in on a
cure for kovid but stop because you had
a jingle recording uh no there wasn't a
lot of jingling during the pandemic
almost all the Arts were shut down
laughter about the pandemic what is
wrong with you people
now what I'd like to do is um
some subliminal messaging that maybe
makes people a little happier about
Conan maybe gets a good positive message
Team Coco radio we hear he's an
incredible love
right just ladies on that one not that I
have any problem with guys too I'll try
anything and I did in college but just
ladies on this one Team Coco radio
we hear he's an incredible love
that's fantastic can that replace bottom
of the Showbiz totem pole well we do
both well you got a lot of space to fill
so he's a 24 7 channel right wait it's
24 7. yeah
yeah
I swear to God I thought I was doing an
hour a week I could just repeat the same
show over and over again like they did
no we did that in the 90s and 2000s okay
here's another one I hear this all the
time Team Coco radio he's much better
looking in person
women say you look so much better in
person maybe some of you thought that I
did yes did you really sure that's when
I came in what were your thoughts
that you're much better looking in
person I usually wear glasses and you
know oftentimes I don't wear glasses so
so you just right now you just see a
blurry Haze I just look like someone
spilled borscht on the rug oh here's one
Team Coco radio he's got the hair and
he's got the brains he's got the body of
a young thing
[Music]
first of all that aha makes everything
sound good no matter what it is try this
the biopsy came back and it looks
worrisome
you know what I gotta say I'm not
worried about I'm not worried about the
biopsy anymore were you tanning a lot in
the 80s always okay that's a mistake
yeah I last went out in the sun during
Ronald Reagan's second Administration
I am like an old very rich Japanese
woman wear gloves and a big hat hey how
about this
body's never seen the Sun
[Music]
that was depressing listen I've tried to
work with these professional singers now
I've only been in the room for maybe
eight minutes you have gone on and on
about your skills in molecular biology
and you told me that uh I'm much better
looking in person mostly because you
have bad eyes what's your story I work
here uh running the Broadway channel on
Broadway and Met Opera radio oh wow yeah
what's your favorite Broadway musical of
all time
that's like choosing your children well
it's easy to do my daughter my daughter
wow got a daughter and a son and she's
just like killing it and he's just like
I don't know whatever we'll see but I
doubt it you know what I mean I have one
request my wife beautiful woman we've
been married 20 years but I'd like a
jingle that's Team Coco radio hey Liza
you could show a little more interest in
Conan's career was she named after Liza
Minnelli no she wasn't Broadway person
not everyone named Liza is named after
Eliza Minnelli it was in shortening of
Elizabeth that existed back in the 1600s
but you Broadway people think everybody
hangs about it
[Music]
it was great having you sing with us do
you really enjoy working with me we've
been doing these for a while without you
and it wasn't not the same of course
it's not the same I'm serious I don't
need to blow my own horn but you know I
mean that's like the Apostle saying you
know I gotta say we were having a pretty
good time and then Jesus showed up and
he kicked things into a whole other gear
duh he's Jesus you guys were all walking
around in your sandals you didn't know
what the hell was going on and then I
walk in the room in kablam that's it
fishes and Loaves the whole nine yards
welp I think I'm done here my career is
over
just compare myself to Christ we don't
know how that goes we are going to move
this thing along but I'm very excited
I'm very excited about the channel and
two of you have brought an incredible
professionalism and you
um we need you in the scientific world
because what you're doing here is not
crucial
this world is cheating on the edge do
you think there's going to be another
viral outbreak in the near future there
already has been we just haven't
identified it yet
[Laughter]
can we do that
Team Coco radio I can't believe they
made us work with this idiot
[Laughter]
[Music]